As I told you guys some time ago, I requested
an absentee ballot in the city of Boston.
I requested one for the September 1st primary
and I requested one for the November 3rd general
election.
And in fact, both my girlfriend and I sent
our applications on the same day two weeks
ago to the city of Boston.
What was really weird was that within five
days she had her absentee ballot already back
and was able to fill it out for the September
1st primary.
And I figured, oh, I'm guessing mine will
get here the next day.
And it didn't.
Well, it's probably just one more day.
Maybe I missed the day's mail with my ballot
and it's going to be delivered to me tomorrow.
Boston's really small.
You know, three miles gets you almost anywhere
in the city proper.
No big deal.
Can't imagine it would be much of a delay.
Well, my absentee ballot didn't come in for
another day or two.
I was away all of last week in the bunker,
as many of you remember.
I figured my ballot will definitely be waiting
for me by the time I get back.
Right.
Got back yesterday.
Still not here.
Started to find it strange.
Now we're only 13 days from the actual primary.
My girlfriend got hers in five days.
She's already sent it in.
Where's my ballot?
I call the city of Boston, city of Boston,
Elections Department explains.
And they say, oh, yeah, we got yours today.
Meaning yesterday, right?
August 17th.
But I sent it on August 2nd.
That's fifteen days.
And my girlfriend sent hers on the same day.
How did my ballot end up delayed two weeks
when we sent our applications out on the same
day.
And the woman at Boston elections says it's
because here we go now it's because of what's
going on with the post office.
Two items.
Letters with a single, you know, just a singles.
Didn't have to stamp it.
But, you know, just a standard letter, not
a package sent on the same day could be delivered
more than 10 days apart.
Now, much the same way.
If I get the ballot today or tomorrow and
send it, could it again be delayed 14 days?
Is that conceivable?
If so, that will be after the September 1st
primary.
Will it still be counted?
It's certainly supposed to be counted.
But if the city of Boston assumes ballots
won't take more than two days here in Boston
because, again, it's a three mile wide city
and then 40 days go by after the primary,
maybe they say, let's stop counting now.
I can't imagine any more ballots are coming
in.
So this is truly a mess.
And remember, this is all by design, limiting
overtime hours so that even though my application
and my girlfriend's application probably arrived
to be sorted on the same day, if you prevent
overtime, you prevent sorting, which prevents
the ballot from being handed to the carrier,
which delays delivery.
And in this case, it delays processing.
This is no joke.
And if this is happening in Massachusetts,
just imagine what is going on in places with
inferior social services and inferior infrastructure
in general.
So needless to say, my plan is to drive my
ballot to city hall in the next few days,
assuming it comes in today or tomorrow.
Now, will this lead to protests because they
actually seemed warranted?
This is a major direct attack on the democratic
systems we thought we had at their core.
People e-mailing me saying, you know, David,
I looked at my ballot.
The online system says my ballot was sent
10 days ago.
Haven't received it.
My town's even smaller than Boston.
It's two miles wide or whatever.
I hate to say it, but to have more certainty
that your vote will be counted.
You might have to vote in person and given
the pandemic, that's horrible and everybody
needs to figure out what's best for them.
What level of risk are you willing to tolerate?
I wish I had better news, but I don't.
But I don't.
We're going to have more coverage of this
on our
Instagram page.